If you recall, when we were discussing
Sudo, we mentioned that it's
a common pattern to disable
the ability to log in as root, and
to only log in as a different user
that has the ability to use Sudo.
This is a security measure,
since every bad guy out there knows
every Linux box has a user named root.
By disabling this
account from remote log,
in we remove a very easy attack vector.
Now vagrant took care of this for us.
They created a user name vagrant and
we just type vagrant ssh from our
terminal to automatically connect.
But not every hosting provider is going
to set something like this up for you.
So let's do this ourselves.